Palestinians say the proposed
middle-east plan put forward by the US
president changes nothing and actually
makes things worse they're still under
Israeli military occupation and gearing
up for more restrictions there was a
small protest in the Jordan Valley on
Wednesday an area that makes up nearly
1/3 of the occupied West Bank a
territory that Israeli Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu has promised to annex
the Israeli army beefed up its presence
in the area and closed off roads
preventing many activists from getting
there hey Jesus Korea the Israeli army
has put up checkpoints in several areas
in the Jordan Valley we had to walk a
lot but we found another checkpoint the
main point is to prevent us from
reaching the areas we agreed to meet and
[Music]
those who did manage to reach the area
were involved in scuffles with his Raley
soldiers
protesters also took to the streets in a
number of West Bank cities including
Bethlehem there the Israeli army used
tear gas and rubber coated steel bullets
to disperse the crowds the anger among
Palestinians has been increasing
especially after the u.s. recognized
Jerusalem as Israel's capital in 2017
Palestinians want occupied East
Jerusalem to be the capital of their
future state and not as the Trump plan
proposes in eastern suburbs to Trump or
whoever else Jerusalem tells its own
story every stone has its history and it
was never an Israeli or an American it
is Palestinian Islamic and the turnout
has been low some of the people we spoke
to say it's the Palestinian Authority
that need to be heading those protests
but there is also a great sense of
apathy here people do not expect much to
change and say that the plan is being
implemented on the ground anyways going
into the street against it even untaught
alia unarmed against Israeli armed
soldiers is a risk and people are
waiting to see how far we go in in
facing the Israeli Menace and the
American Menace leaders of Hamas in Gaza
have also condemned the proposed plan
enough Norman faith that our message was
clear we object to the so-called deal of
the century this is why we must stand
united and work hand in hand in order to
confront this conspiracy against our
people we must have a unified national
strategy to restore our people's rights
to end the division once and for all
with Israeli elections only a few weeks
away many years think Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu may start the
enacting of some Palestinian territory
sooner rather than later
nnedi Brahimi al Jazeera the occupied
West Bank